the big thing is just I think the
markets have been trying to adapt number
one to the new economic data coming out
of China about the issues in the Chinese
economy and then the other thing is
American companies you guys have covered
this extensively global currencies have
really moved against American
multinationals in the line just in the
last you know six months and I think
frankly I think Wall Street was slow to
adapt to the reality now that the dollar
as much stronger versus all the other
currencies and you know when a big
company comes and says we missed our
numbers because of currency changes the
presumption from investors it's an
excuse in the last six months a lot of
that has actually been true and so I
think people are adjusting to this new
currency world I think though the
currency shift is reflected the US is
doing really well there are issues in
many other countries in the rest of the
world that the US is doing really well
and I think for from a u.s. standpoint
things are going pretty well so build
early-warning startups to prioritize
profitability overgrowth Marc Benioff
told me earlier this week he thinks
there's going to be a lot of dead
unicorns ahead how do you think the
shakeout looks when it comes to private
tech what does it look like on your side
of the equation look so it's these these
are starting i guess i would say I think
situation normal these are startups some
of them are going to work really well
some of them run are going to not work
at all in some environments it's easier
to raise money it makes sense to prepare
for environments and which is not as
easy to raise money to me that doesn't
translate into a call for everybody to
panic I think each company should figure
out its own strategy actually get us
some strategy and that's what we work
with our companies to do so last
question if Sequoia if the head of the
headline on sequoias slide deck in 2008
is our IP good times what is andreessen
horowitz say right now well that's
that's reflects a quiz extremely smart
firm but that's reflective which is 2008
was not our AP good times and so our
general attitude I don't know if we have
a headline but it's it's it's be
measured be cautious be careful but also
investing growth and we have companies
that are growing fast we don't tell them
to pull back as the stock market whips
in fact if anything we tell them to push
forward and go take down the market and
so for the companies are doing well I
think they're going to do really well um
you're big on founder CEOs what do you
think should happen at Twitter up so I'm
reflexively in favor of founders running
these companies whenever possible and so
I think if Jack or ever some combination
of the two ended up and leaders you know
back in leadership at Twitter I think
that'd be great